uh should we start
sure
okay
uh good morning everybody online
at the auditorium uh it's a great
pleasure to have richard zamel from
colombia university talking about
learning uninformative representations
uh
uh rich take it away
all right thanks a lot
um
yeah so i'd like to keep the talk
informal so if you have a question or
comment please speak up and if i don't
hear you can somebody just notify me and
let me know somebody's trying to say
something okay thanks
all right let me
so
so
the talk today is going to be about
representation learning and
generally the way representation
learning has been formulated for many
years now the idea was you wanted to
find some representation that maximizes
mutual information between z and x so
this was linskir's infomax principle
from 1988
and that dates back even further it
relates to the redundancy reduction
ideas
for biological processing that horace
barlow suggested in 61 that keeps coming
up in the unsupervised learning context
um
and you know everybody knows about one
application of this which was ita right
the aim was to decompose and put into
uh independent components typically
formulated as non-gaussian that retain
all the information in
in x
but what i'm going to focus on is how in
many contexts the real aim we want to do
is remove information about particular
quantities in the input so let me start
by giving some
some examples about that from from
different applications and different
scenarios
so in one case you have you want to
remove spurious feature you want to
learn some predictor but part of that
prediction
you know is going to rely on some
features that you don't want it to right
so those are the spurious features so
this is an example from
uh some colleagues in health they told
me about that you build a if you build
predictor for diabetes based on health
data typically from north america often
from mostly white patients is that the
primary predictor for diabetes is the
body mass index or bmi
but then you take that same predictor
and you try to apply it to a different
uh culture
uh and that doesn't work at all like in
asia as you see here in this curve
there's not the same relationship
between
uh you know diabetes and and uh body
mass index so it's that varying
relationship means that you want to
factor that out and find other other
important features that allow you to
predict uh diabetes better all right so
the question is how to remove these
kinds of spurious features when you're
building a predictor
another example
is an old idea from
again from
machine learning of the information
bottleneck and in that one the idea is
you wanted to learn some representation
t
that
uh
if you're going to minimize the or the
negative mutual information between t
and some target y or maximizing
information the t contains about y and
otherwise minimize the information that
t has about x so you're in a sense
extracting all only the information
about x that's relevant to y and
removing all the other uh and from
irrelevant information from x
same type of things come up
in the recent uh you know it's been a
flurry of work on self-supervised
learning so here's a uh
an image from one of those papers and
they define what they call the info min
principle so here you have so in the
picture you'll see you have the frog on
the left and then you have two images
you know two augmentations of that frog
and the idea is those two different
views of the frog you want to
maximize the information that each of
them has about some target y
and then remove all the other
information that those views have with
each other so that's dated down below
right maximize information in each view
and why and minimize the mutual
information between
those two views and so if you look on
the right you can see that you know
rather than
you want to push the information that
between v1 and v2 down because otherwise
you're going to retain lots of
irrelevant information
same type of things
come up recently and another called
domain generalization where the aim is
to learn you know
representations that apply to lots of
different uh domains so here's the
domain looking at different
classification problems you have images
and you want to classify them into
digits or into various uh other kinds of
categories like
offices or
uh different aspects of land and then
also different styles of input different
kinds of domains like you know
handwritten versus
drawn versus natural images okay and so
here you assume that every example has
some side information that says what
environment the data comes from and the
goal in a sense is to minimize this loss
across all environments
what that really means is you're trying
to lose information about the
environment right and remove that
information
so we'll say a little more about that
because i'm going to talk more about it
so
so it's called invariant learning is the
the kind of
approach to domain generalization so you
want to predict the invariant features
from these environments that you've seen
during training you're defining just
those features that can predict the
class label that regardless the
environment so you're losing information
about the specific environment so one
instance of this that was defined a
couple years ago was the invariant risk
minimization
you have some inputs x from environment
e and labels y from that same
environment and you find some
transformation
so that the probability of the label y
from that environment
given the representation phi of xe so
phi is a transform that it takes the
input x into some new representation
so so conditioned on that representation
the probability of y should be the same
across all environments okay so it's the
same across all environments i'll say
something more about that in a few
minutes
so here's a simple illustration of it
though
that's a you know contrived example
where you color endless digits you take
so you know some are red some are green
and you divide them into two class
classes right so the low digits the zero
to four are class one class and the high
digits five and nine are another class
and then what we have is
during training you have a
big kind of standard colorization so
that the red digits uh the low digits
tend to be red and the high digits tend
to be green
all right so uh if a predictor will tend
to focus on the color rather than the
actual shape
and they and they enhance this by adding
label noise so that the
shape isn't always a very good predictor
of the uh
of the actual digit class okay
and then we have two different
environments where the correlation
between the color and the digit changes
so one of them it's 0.8 that the low
digits are red and the other one is 0.9
probability that the low digits are red
and so it's the key is this difference
between those two so that when you want
to train an invariant predictor it's
going to learn that this relationship
between the environment and the color
isn't stable whereas the relationship
between the shape and color doesn't vary
between the environments
and so that's what happens when you
train uh some like standard erm
uh and you test on the training data you
see you get like 84 correct but when you
test when you switch the uh coloring so
that the low digits are now green and
the high digits are red you only get
those predictor only gets 10 correct but
when you train with this something
that's ignoring the uh
noticing that the color varies between
the environments and factoring that out
and removing that information then you
get consistent classification on the
training and test and the reason why
it's only 70 is because of this uh label
noise
okay so it's a bit of a contrived
example but it gets across this idea
that what you want to do is remove
information that's environment specific
in order to learn what you really care
about these invariant features
and then the last kind of context in
which information removal comes up is in
algorithmic fairness
so the last one at least for the purpose
of the talk um so in fair representation
learning this is the setup i want to
describe so the typical idea in fairness
is that you're doing some classification
problem you have some input data x you
want to predict some label y and we'll
call y hat the model prediction and then
you have some sensitive attribute that
you've defined for now we're going to
think of it as a single sensitive
attribute and that could just you know
correspond to race or gender age
something like that and you want to
learn a classifier that's not not only
accurate but it's fair with respect to a
and there's lots of different
definitions of fairness i'm not going to
get into what that second criteria means
in this talk
um so but how does the fair
representation learning come into it so
the
the formulation is that we're learning
this fair classification which maps x to
some representation z
and then something else that's mapping z
to our prediction y hat so we have an
encoder f and the classifier g
and the representation fair
representation actually focuses not on
[Music]
but why because the representation z and
the goal for z is that it should
maintain the useful information in x but
at the same time yield fair but at the
same time be fair
such that the downstream classifier is
fair for all vendors g that you could
use that same representation for any g
and it would retain uh fairness
properties so you want to remove so one
way to do this is to remove information
about the sensitive attribute a from the
representation z
so that's my list of uh
applications or areas in which
information removal is important now
what are some methods i'm just going to
briefly talk about a couple methods the
people have formed kinds of methods that
people have used for information removal
and one of them is distribution matching
uh so here you wanna have in mind that
you might have
two distributions you have the
distributions of representations that
come from
you know uh
one
setting for the information you want to
remove and a second distribution for the
second setting for the information you
want to remove you can have more than
two settings for that variable right now
we're gonna think of it as binary but
imagine we just have these two different
settings just for ease of understanding
and so each of those has some
distributions over representations and
if we can make those two distributions
match then we've removed information
about the
underlying
variable that we want to
remove from the representation
okay so one way to do that is to match
moments of the distribution so you can
look at distance between statistics of
those distributions so the uh you know
we have this uh 5x that's our psi of x
that's our uh statistics and we're going
to remove information and so one way is
using mmd that you know arthur greten
who's going to talk soon
so you know he'd find this maximum mean
discrepancy this kind of
uh way of matching the moments based
just on samples from those distributions
right so that can be expressed using
this kind of kernel trick that says
we're going to look at the you know you
can expand the the square here and get
these terms that have to do with uh
kernels applied to samples from within
one of the uh distributions or between
the two distributions
and so we've done this in the apply this
in the fairness context we want to
remove information about the sensitive
variable a where we have an a
regularizer this mmd regularizer that is
uh using this idea to try to match
moments of the distribution so we've
removed information about the in the
representation about our
underlying sensitive variable
okay a second method is adversarial
so
uh and in that case we
we defined some computational you know
description of an adversary so here's
another picture from a fairness setup
where
we have
uh it's the same kind of notation as
before we have some input x we have some
representation z that we're learning and
some classifier that's trying to predict
y from z
and
we have this adversary that's taking the
representation z and predict trying to
predict a right so it's trying to figure
out what is the information that z
contains about a
um and we're trying to the aim is to
define a representation that removes the
thwarts the adversary right doesn't
allow the adversary to predict a
so
we we have a we had a twist on that in
our work we had a twist on the adversary
where it's not just trying to remove
information given z but we have there's
other definitions of fairness that
actually rely on
the
not that the uh fairness isn't in
general that the information should be
removed from z but it's conditioned on y
alright so that is there's a something
called equalized odds one of the
definitions of fairness that says you
know that the errors that the uh
um that the classifier makes should be
balanced between the groups so that that
errors is is dependent on the actual
class y as well as the model's
prediction
so the adversary for that kind of
fairness criteria also has to have
access to y so there's a missing little
arrow that goes from y in this diagram
that so so the adversary now has access
to both z and y when it tries to predict
a
right and so we have these two
these loss functions down here that are
defined
for the adversary right in the adversary
in one case is sort of something called
demographic parity which is the one that
the standard one where you're trying to
just in general remove information that
z has about a
uh and then
so here we have these different
distributions
uh
where
in this case
the um
drawn where you for x and a pairs and
the second distribution it's uh it
depends on on y okay
anyways the main idea here is that with
this whole suite of adversarial methods
that have been applied in fairness and
obviously lots of other contexts
so now i want to focus the talk on a
problem which is saying what happens if
we don't know the environment variables
or the labels um and so in this case the
idea is that we want to remove
information but we don't really even
know what information we want to remove
okay and that comes up in a lot of
context we don't
in many cases we don't know it or that
they might even be sub-optimal so
this is the case uh and same thing
appears in fairness if you think of the
environment labels as equivalent to
the sensitive attributes right so you're
dividing you can think of the
environment labels as dev partitioning
the input into different groups
different uh
uh different spaces in a sense right and
now so it's the same type of thing in
fairness where you're now partitioning
the inputs into into different groups
um
in fairness there's been some recent
studies
where
you don't have access to the attributes
you don't really even know which are the
important attributes so it's called
subgroup fairness where you don't know
the demographic label so there's you
know two studies that came out on this a
few years ago one called
multi-calibration the other one fairness
gerrymandering
and this is a real problem and
especially in fairness because so an
example um
you know this is a paper that's um you
know that
when you might not have access to this
uh this sensitive attribute is like you
have unobserved characteristics an
example is you know the uh queer
communities this is a important
consideration for that that community
all right so this is a real problem
where you don't necessarily know the
environment label or the sensitive
attributes so the aim an important aim
is to say how can we figure out what the
environments are that will help identify
those features
and
so that in the context we're talking
about how do i identify what information
we want to be removed from a given
representation right because we aren't
told ahead of time you know remove the
bmi from the diabetes predictor or you
know remove information about particular
sensitive attributes
so we're going to focus on the recent
paper written with my grad student
elliot my postdoc yorn who's now moved
on to uh position at apple
so to start with we're going to
introduce some notation and definitions
um
so we're going to have an input space x
we have a set of environments or domains
and a target space y representation
space h right so our observational data
comes in these triplets where we have x
y and e all right that's where our
data is drawn from and we have some loss
function
um and we have a predictor so this is in
the case sorry to this is in the case
where environments are known so far okay
and i'm going to transition to the case
where environments aren't known they
have a predictor that's some linear
classifier on top of the representation
okay so we've learned some
representation and have a simple
classifier right so this is
very common and what i talked about
earlier like self-supervised learning
and so we have this our model that we're
concerned with is what's learning the
representation so it's mapping x to some
space h so that's the phi of x i
introduced before
so standard erm learning is you know
just the loss and the representation
based on the representation phi of x and
y
where we draw examples from this the
triplet of x y and e
so the related problems like domain
generalization says how can we get low
error rates on
where we draw samples x and y from some
in
based on some test environment where
that test environment wasn't observed
and domain adaptation
is a
version of there's a lot of different
definitions but one definition that i
like is where we can same idea but we
can take those model parameters and
adapt them at test time using unlabeled
examples right
so these are all related to this kind of
this formulation
so the invariant learning problem right
is to learn this representation 5x
that's going to work across environments
and i just want to so one thing we
should study in this paper is the
relationship between invariant learning
and fairness it hasn't really been
appreciated much but i think there's a
lot of interesting parallels and
synergies between the two so one example
is this one so in the
uh irm that what i mentioned before the
invariant risk minimization
size the environment
so this is uh an important component so
it's what the environment's converge
constraint says imagine we have two
environments e1 and e2
we draw examples from both of those
the
idea is that the expected value of y
given our model that maps x to phi of x
so for particular values of condition on
particular values of phi of x
in environment one for those examples
the expected value of y should match the
expected value of y
given the 5x is the same value for
examples drawn from environment two
right so you're invariant to the
environment the representation learned
is invariant to the environment
all right
and this can be generalized to multiple
environments but just easiest to think
about too now
so this was defined in the paper in the
irm paper
earlier the definition in the fairness
community had something called group
sufficiency which really is almost
exactly the same
we want to match the expected value of y
given s of x and e for all e and so here
e instead of the environments are the
sensitive groups
that i mentioned before
one difference is that s of x is a
little bit different than 5x s of x is
really like the logits of your
classifier it's not necessarily a
representation space but it's the logits
of the classifier
may i ask a question regarding the use
of this constraint for fairness so i
guess you know
some particular age would be you know
you know make you
with high probability get a loan why
but you know there's the other issue
right that uh maybe from from
environment e1 i go to that very golden
age with very high probability and if
i'm from environment two i don't go to
that age with
uh high probability right so i mean
could you comment a little bit on what
what type of fairness this enforces
because uh right
yeah it could be
right so the id yes so if you define
your representations basically that you
know another way to think about that i
think is that
some portion of representation space is
devoted to environment one and a
separate portion of the devoted
environment too so the environment
variance constraint is satisfied
somewhat trivially because you never
have this overlap or it's very rare to
have this overlap in terms of their
representations and yeah so that's a
an issue in this definition i mean in
this definition both from i think irm
and from
you know fairness it's not unique to
fairness right so irm it
um
won't generalize to new environments
very well when this happens right so in
other words
the aim here is to learn things that are
invariant across
representations that are invariant
across uh environments but if the
representations are devoted to
environments there's no saying what's
going to happen when you try to have a
new environment right so it's the same
the same issue so it's obvious it's not
sufficient i agree to define either as a
fairness constraint or as a kind of
learning constraint
um
and
you know so the group's efficiency is a
is not applying and that it's more
difficult than the group's efficiency
because now you've mapped things down to
a logic space the one-dimensional logic
space
and that as and so it's possible even
there that you can kind of finally you
know have a granularity such that
the s different portions of the logit
space are
devoted for different environments and
you won't have this this issue either
right uh so yes it says it is a problem
and and this is usually most of these
are regularizers though so that the
question is whether you're able to do
this and still do a very good job on
your um
on your classification task right so you
so uh it's you know if you have a rich
enough model class such that you can do
this and have you know the represent
enough representation space so that each
environment gets its own representation
and do a good job on classification then
it's uh you know it's a kind of an
overfitting problem in some sense you
have to rich a model class for the
problem
okay so one is so um
so here's a one way that we've defined
for uh
environment
for learning an environment okay where
you don't aren't given it okay so that's
the goal now we aren't given the
environment and we're trying to
capitalize on the idea that learning
systems tend to find shortcuts so this
is a kind of canonical example of that
you train up a learning system on cows
on grass to identify cows and the
learning system will focus on the
environment right that it's the grass or
the background and so cows running
through uh the surf won't be uh detected
as cows
so
so the system finds shortcuts easy ways
of protecting cows that are invariant to
different kinds of cows
very into the background have
environments defined based on shortcut
then invariant learning is going to be
focus on features that we don't want it
to like the background okay so think
about that they came up also in our
synthetic example about color mnist
where the
the shortcut classifier relied on color
so
if we had an environment though that
where e1 the first environment where all
red digits and e2 were all green digits
and then we trained up in a
classifier to be invariant to the
environments then it would be invariant
to color all right so the color features
are then not invariant across these
these domains
uh so this is the motivating idea the
kind of simple idea that says okay maybe
what we could do is
assume that our system is going to find
shortcuts and use the and capitalize on
that to define worst-case environments
so if we're trying to satisfy this
environment and variance constraint
[Music]
we define a per environment risk so
we're drawing examples from x y a given
you know some environment trying to
minimize loss on that
so the actual irm what it regular it
it's
you know minimizing the environment and
variance constraint is not simple right
because you're then conditioning on five
x equals h
and so how are you going to actually
evaluate that for
uh you know high dimensional
representation space
uh and look for what case where they
match and so instead what they optimize
is a differential proxy differentiable
proxy to that which relies on the uh
gradients uh
being minimized across environments all
right
and so that's the actual thing that they
minimize as a regularizer on top of um
you know classification performance
so our our approach is to define our
worst case environment by maximizing
this eaic so we're going to have some
classifier some reference classifier
we'll call it that comes up with an
initial fi that we're assuming relies on
shortcuts right it's going to use things
that spurious features that it shouldn't
like background features or color or
things like that that aren't the
invariants
and so then we're going to use that idea
to then say okay well now we're going to
try to maximize this uh environment of
variance constraint given that so we're
going to try to the adversaries in a
sense
the environment definition is kind of
adversarial it's going to be the worst
case environment for us and then we're
going to minimize uh turn around and
minimize given those that environment
definition minimize this
pic or any kind of invariant learning
constraint
so here's a summary
so instead of having handcrafted
environments we're going to start with
some reference model like i said we're
going to train up an initial classifier
that we're going to assume
is going to learn some sort of spurious
features
and it defines these putative and
variant features but those typically
won't be what we want like it might be
the color and the endless ideas in the
mnist color in this experiment
and then we're going to do environment
assignment per example using a bernoulli
probability queue
all right so here's the algorithm sketch
we find some reference model by tilda
we fixed that one and then we optimized
the inner loop to infer the environment
so we infer these assignments of for
each example i to an environment
by
uh
using q that's going to be maximizing
the uh this proxy this eic proxy
then we fix that cue which is fixing in
the environment assignments and now
we're going to optimize the outer loop
which is the original
invariant learning which is going to
optimize both for classification plus
this regularizer okay
so and how does this do on color and
this it actually outperforms
uh
erm which isn't a big surprise uh an erm
like we said when you train erm and then
test it where you've switched the color
definitions so that the red what was the
low digits are now green instead of red
it does badly
irm which uses the handcrafted
environments iron you know that
environment one environment the
between environments the
correlations between color and digit
switches
so irm actually you know does much
better than erm but in our case when we
learn our
our environments rather than hand
crafting them we do uh considerably
better on
test performance in ira
we also tested on some other synthetic
data sets of water birds is another
example where we have
you know birds that tend to appear on
water uh on water backgrounds and and
birds that tend to appear on land on
land backgrounds
and the uh
aim is
or that's a water
bird so the background again is a is a
very kind of good cue but there's going
to be some examples where it's switched
all right and then what we want to do is
measure the worst crew performance that
is in the worst group performance are
the land birds that at test time appear
on water and the water birds that appear
on land backgrounds
and so
erm does very badly on this worst group
performance because they're very
infrequent in the data set
there's another method called uh group
distributionally robust optimization
that can do well on this but it's told
what the groups are it's told that you
know water birds are on water and land
birds are on land in our case we're
going to infer the environment and then
optimize based on those inferred
environments so we're going to use their
same oracle thing but without the
handcrafted environments or kind of
domain knowledge about the environments
instead we're going to do our first step
of defining the environments inferring
what the environments are and then
optimizing and we do quite well on uh
tests on this worst group that is the
water birds on lando and birds on water
okay
um and maybe to leave time for questions
i'll i'll skip some of this but the idea
here was well just to briefly summarize
is that
you know this isn't a
foolproof method by any means it really
depends on the reference model the
assumption is that the reference model
has learned a spurious feature and when
the reference model hasn't learned spurs
features that the reference model is
good and ignores color for example in
the color mnist and actually figures out
on shape then our method is not going to
improve on things so it's really the
question of whether these kind of
initial model the reference model is
focusing on
not on the features that we really care
about that we that's what our method
relies on i see there's something in the
chat let me take a look and see if i can
answer that
how do you prevent learning the truly
important so that's what i was just
saying i think so the answer to that is
you aren't preventing it you're assuming
that
there's going to be some not some the
initial reference model is going to
learn it right so we have no control
over what that is going to learn so one
way you can do that is assuming that the
spurious features are simple so there's
been other met other people have
attempted something similar there's some
other work that came out around the same
time or just after hours there's a
method called just train twice
uh or another one called the too good to
be true prior and all our method and
these other methods all rely on this
idea in some sense the too good to be
true idea which is like saying we're
gonna have some prior that says the
initial model is too good it you know
appears to be good but it's not really
that good it's the whole idea of
shortcuts so we're relying on the idea
that the initial model is going to find
shortcuts if the initial model is really
good and it doesn't find shortcuts then
these methods aren't going to improve
right so it's still a good open question
of how are we going to find environments
infer environments when we aren't don't
know them at all and so this is one idea
about how to do that which is to assume
that the environments are defined in a
sense by
uh you know an initial models uh
locking onto spurious features
so wait there's another question in the
chat let me see if i can pull that one
up
okay
same
person
lost my mouse to get rid of that okay
okay so good so just
want to leave some time for some
discussion and questions so let me just
summarize about eel what we call this
method is eel for environment inference
for invariant learning so
our aim is discover to discover
environments and it's like i said it has
this parallels on work that's gone on
very interesting work that i hear
wherever i encourage you to look at that
there's all kinds of work going on in
the
fairness community on this basic idea
about multi-calibration which is uh
which is
um the idea that you want to have
fairness defined not just for a single
group but for multiple groups and in
many cases the idea is that those groups
can be the not necessarily predefined
those groups can be defined based on
some
uh
some simple computational circuit that's
going to look at the input and define
what's in a group and you're going to do
this repeatedly so like the
multi-calibration approach is a really a
boosting approach where every round
you're going to find a new
simple computational circuit that looks
at the input and defines group
membership that's the worst case group
according to your current message method
and then
refine your classifier to do well on the
worst case group and that's the
the second round of the boosting so
again you iterate through this um
in a standard boosting style but that's
also relying on the idea that you have
this worst case this so it's uh similar
to ours where you want to define as a
worst case method uh approach to define
what the environments or in our in that
case what the
worst case groups are with respect to
fairness
that's what i was challenging about is
that it's really dependent on the model
so the question is can we infer what the
target environments are and more
generally what kind of distribution
shift what kind of new environments do
we really want to target so i think this
is a really important open question
that's you know more general now about
this is really about domain
generalization and questions about how
much how much can we really expect the
system to generalize to new environments
right so i think that the
this field is really in its infancy for
this and i think it's a real interesting
open questions about what what is
reasonable to expect and ask about our
systems in terms of what they should
generalize to
and then maybe more pertinent to the
topic of the direct topic of the
workshop is that the current methods we
have for removing information from
representations really aren't uh
satisfactory or they aren't quite what
we want so i mentioned distribution
matching that doesn't scale up very well
to very kind of high dimensional
continuous representation space that are
being learned in in these kinds of
models
and adversarial methods are attractive
but as everybody knows right there's
like all kinds of computational
challenges in trying to do this and the
whole mini max problem that uh is really
a difficult optimization
um
and
you know and then there's this other
idea that came up from talked about in
irm there's this differential proxy but
it's really not understood and i think
an interesting question to say how do
those relate to the desired and variance
properties right so that's another kind
of open question i think interesting and
relevant and i'll stop there thanks
uh thank you very much for uh for a very
interesting talk uh rich um
i'm sure there are questions i have
several but uh is there any question
from the uh auditorium
first
okay so let me start with one question
that i have so um
um
so i'm still trying to wrap my head
around the objective function uh but but
could you comment a little bit on like
is there a let's say baby uh theoretical
setting
like uh
like you know like learning mixtures of
regressions or like
so some like baby stylistic stylistic
model where
i can interpret uh your objective
function as trying to
you know estimate that model
uh is like yeah
um
right
let's see so the objective is
uh let me think about that um
right so we have
um
yes we the model
assumes that there are both spurious
features and kind of you know signal
features and noise features
right
and
you know and that's questionable
assumption but for the sake of our our
baby example we'll do that um and
the
so the model is going to um
have some representation that's going to
be potentially containing both sets of
features all right and so
the
trying to map this to like not really a
mixture model so much but you can think
of it yeah there are if the features can
be clearly identified as either
uh
spurious or noise features all right
then
um
right then you can say
the environment and variance objective
that you're asking about before right is
saying that the
um
what defines the noise features
is or the what defines the uh signal
features
is that they are invariant across
environments so we have to have some
environment uh the data is drawn from
you know yet some data is drawn from
environment one some data is drawn from
environment two in both cases we'll have
noise features and signal features and
so the aim is to
in a sense remove the noise features and
just focus on the signal features all
right so
uh you know so you have a lot you know
think of it as a vector of features and
and and we want to just eliminate this
set that our noise features and and
preserve the ones that are our signal
features um
so i think we could define that as a a
mixture model where we're gonna you know
or some sort of generative model we're
gonna first choose the environment given
the environment we're gonna choose the
the set of features both from the noise
pool and the and the invariant pool and
then generate the input given that so
that's how i would think of it as a you
know a generative model and now we want
to invert that model
for the noise for the features
but there is i guess i guess the point
of my
a bit confusion is i guess in the
example of uh
you know like
water birds on land and i don't know
like uh
uh
i guess you know like uh you know like
there must be some overlap property
between i mean uh between you know
um
because otherwise i could very well
latch on the
on the wrong features and they're
informative for the examples that i've
seen right so there is
so there is this in the synthetic
examples both for color and this and for
i mean the water birds is as an example
just to stick to that one right there is
it's it's too synthetic in a way so
right so if you focus on the background
right um
then you'll do very well on uh on almost
all the examples
um and not do that well on the uh
you know the the rare ones which have
the water birds on land advice and
lamberts of water
and so erm they're just taking advantage
of the fact that erm is going to you
know focus on the majority of the
examples uh which is you know uh where
the it's considered they're consistent
so
the
um
more generally i think there is this
issue which is that there's a strong
correlation between often
you don't you can't completely ignore
some set of features so it could be i
think what you're getting at is that
you know it could be that some the
features aren't clearly either noise or
signal there's good or or there's going
to be some mixture right and so the real
thing is that i think the real problem
is that you and there's going to be
interesting correlations between these
things so the real what you really want
to be able to do is identify sets of
features that are more invariant than
others and capitalize on those when you
go to domain generalization so you're
going to allow a system to learn some
features that may be very used very kind
of domain specific or specific to a
small set of domains and other ones that
are fairly invariant and as long as you
have identified those then you should
expect a good generalization because
you're going to allow the system to
learn you know and use the features that
are more invariant so that when you
generalize to the environment so i think
the i'm not sure if this is exactly
answering your question but in my view
of it there's it's not this strict
definition of you know either noise or
or signal features right that you can
you know find things that are
relevant to the signal in both you know
many features are relevant to the signal
on both but some but the idea is that
there are going to be some features that
are more relevant uh across many
environments and those are the invariant
ones you want to focus on
all right so like the bmi example is one
where they're that case they know what
the spur is that one spurious feature is
you don't want to focus on bmi but you
can train up another classifier that
ignores bmi there could be some other
features that you find that are still
pretty indicative and informative and
you want to keep those but you want to
know that those are kind of domains
specific so that when you then train on
some new you know some new uh i don't
know groups that you can
allow the ones that are are more
invariant to dominate
yeah thank you i i guess i have to think
about a
situation where
you know i can say you know like uh
under the such and such condition uh the
right thing is identifiable and uh
yeah
but i think it would go kind of like how
do you describe like a generative model
where
uh there's a predictive feature and a
noise feature and yeah
yeah
um it look like there's something in the
chat here
are there
human in the loop solutions to this well
i think the diabetes example is a human
in the loop right so the human the
domain experts know in that case that
bmi it turns out isn't a very good
predictor whether those humans
knew before i'm sure they knew before
there were any classifiers trained but
maybe you know you have to go study the
new culture and find that the
correlations are different than the new
culture so i think that there's
certainly a lot of room for humans to
try to identify what features tend to be
noise and what natures tend not to be
noise
and
like for the in for the environment idea
or or you know for the fairness idea we
have some definition of what we think
are
definitions of demographic groups and
what we want to be fair to include those
demographic groups
but we also think there's other things
that may not be as obvious right so i
think it's an interesting situation
where
there's things that we know we have to
be fair to about you know race and
gender and things like that but they're
or something that
or things that aren't very observable in
the data that you know we don't know
ahead of time and so i think there's
some mix between human knowledge and
what's known ahead of time versus the
actual the system defining groups and
then maybe a human then has to come in
and say is this a group that we're
worried about is this a group that we
want to be invariant to you know uh and
so i think there is
and so ideally there's some
interpretability there too where you can
identify what groups are enough that
somebody can look at it and say yeah
that's something that's you know
something that we can that we should be
concerned about and make sure that the
system's you know fair to that group
um how can this line of methods connect
to the re-weighting method which is also
common yes so so re-weighting i think is
is the idea that like an erm so like
with the waterbirds example is something
where you can try to combat it by saying
well it's very rarely do you see water
birds on land in the dataset and rarely
if you see land birds on water you
always see you know water birds water
lamborghini land and so why don't we if
we know ahead of time we can re-weight
right we can say you know put much more
weight on the loss of uh those
uh those rare examples
um so i have a couple comments on that
one is that
re-weighting is
okay in some sense it doesn't
there's been some interesting work on
showing that that doesn't always solve
the problem right so it's re-weighting
isn't isn't uh going to be the the
answer i mean one
one thing is that you know there's just
just by re-weighting it doesn't mean
that you're going to actually learn a
classifier that generalizes well to new
examples from that infrequent
distribution
um
and
uh
and then
the second point is that
uh more to what what i was focused on in
the eel is that re-weighting assumes
that you know what the distributions are
ahead of time you've identified them so
you can reweight them right so here the
idea was can we infer which are the
distributions that are less uh
you know that has to be reweighted but
we don't know it ahead of time so that's
this dual problem of finding the
which which are the kind of you know
infrequent
examples what's the that hasn't been
sampled enough and then one way to solve
it is by
doing re-weighting or some of these
other invariant learning methods that
have other
approaches to re-weighting so i can
think of these you know the invariant uh
principles like the eaic one i talked
about is is an alternative in a sense to
re-weighting it's an alternative that
says well rather than re-weighting the
data we're going to have this constraint
that we want to fit to the data so we
have a paper you could think of where we
actually tried to explore and compare
re-weighting to some of these other
examples in uh in these contexts and
found that to be honest none of them are
so far i would say are that status
that's satisfactory uh so that's a paper
we had at uh
at the last nurips that we called nooch
so if you look that up you'll at least
see some empirical studies of it that
just doesn't doesn't suggest something
better it shows that what we have
currently is isn't great
can these be combined such as learn the
weights at the same time so i think
that's really what we're trying to do
here
is learn the weights adversarially right
so you think of that's what we're doing
is we're saying
trying to defy so we so
like the water birds on land the
lamborghini water think of that as we
don't have we have some group that is uh
uh you know undersampled in the data set
or underrepresented in our data set so
you know you could think of this in a
fairness context or you know in the
birds on water kind of context we aren't
being fair to those land birds that live
on on water um so
we want to so
we don't know ahead of time that the
important thing is if we don't know
ahead of time that the background
uh with the label the correlation
between that is what defines the groups
that are you know undersampled right so
that's what we're trying to do is
adversarially say look this is a this is
an inv this is a group
that is
uh
kind of worst case group in a sense
group that's going to be not treated
very well and then when once we define
that worst case group then we're going
to try to optimize
so ours is one way of doing it there's
others that have other ways of doing
this so you could say there's you know
work on
uh another kind of method is conditional
uh variance at risk
which tries to focus on the loss of the
examples that have the the worst case
loss right so that's like saying you
know you take some parameter alpha and
say we're going to make sure we don't
care about the rest of the examples
we're going to train up train a
classifier find which are the worst case
ones and then ensure that the worst case
ones have at least a
reasonable loss right it shouldn't be
too low so that's another form of this
and there's other things like uh
uh distribution groups optimization
you'll be training so those are all of
this flavor like you're trying to define
the groups that are the worst off in
some sense and optimize on those one
difference between those methods and
ours and that this is ours is more of a
distinct iteration so those are kind of
one unified objective where you you kind
of focus on the worst case loss and
ensure that that's
optimized throughout
ours is more uh the boosting style thing
where you're gonna go back and forth and
there's pluses and minuses to those two
that you know that we could discuss but
uh but those are but in a sense all of
these are
aiming at the same thing which is in
some sense trying to define
which are the kinds of examples that are
not being treated well and can we then
make a classifier that does well you
know uh at least reasonably well on on
all of those and like and so
you can think of that as if we could
think of it as the worst case ones
have some and information that define
them okay that's what we're trying to do
we're trying to define what is the
information that defines those right so
it's like the color and color mnist or
you know it could be some
uh demographic information in the case
of fairness and then ensure that the
system is uh good for those then you're
satisfying the
kind of worse worst case so that's so
going back to my theme was about
removing information you want to have
the information about those groups
not be pre be obvious in the
representation because if it's obvious
in the representation then the system
can you know potentially you know make
use of that information and do badly on
one group or another
but i do think that that's you know
there's this underlying question of
you know in fairness it's so
often in these cases the real focus is
on trans
generalization to something new it's
about transfer learning in some sense
right so that's what the domain
generalization is inherently that way
that's the way we formulated the kind of
fairness in the representation learning
for fairness is that you're learning
representations that ideally transfer in
a new context maybe to a new data set or
to a new context and so all of these
really focus on the transfer context
it's not about you know iid data it's
some new new data set and so that's
that's the real motivation in some sense
for
removing the information because you
think that some information that seems
to be relevant in your training data may
not be relevant when it comes to your
your test scenarios right so i think
that's the real focus in all of these
cases it's really about transfer to some
new new domain and that goes back to my
point here about what kinds of shifts
are reasonable for us to work on right
so the diabetes predictor you know
certainly it's reasonable to try to use
that for i don't know different
populations i think in a lot of our
classification examples in the machine
learning that may not have like a real
health application but other cases you
know what kind of
how what kind of
shifts do we want to really uh build our
system to be robust to
and i think that our current method of
doing you know one data set and then
testing on another data set
is uh isn't very um principled in a way
right we want to think about what what
space are we talking about that we
really want to shift uh and be able to
learn a classifier in one cent space and
shift it to another
all right uh thank you very much again
reeds for the great talk
okay all right thank you
all right
good and i'll uh
see you later this afternoon on zoom
okay thanks